broadly looking at history when you look
at genghis khan when you look at stalin
hitler the darkest moments of human
history
what do you take away from those moments
does it help you gain insight about
human nature about human behavior today
whether it's the wars or the individuals
or just the behavior of people any
aspects of history
yeah i find history fascinating
um
um there's a lot of incredible things
that have been done good and bad um
that they
help
help you understand
the nature of
civilization um
and individuals and
does it make you sad that humans do
these kinds of things to each other you
look at the 20th century world war ii
the cruelty the abuse of power
talk about
communism marxism and stalin um
i mean some of these things do i mean if
you
like there's a lot of human history um
most of it is
actually people just getting on with
their lives uh you know and and it's not
like
human history is just
uh what non-stop war and disaster is but
those are actually just those are
intermittent and rare and if they
weren't then
you know humans would soon cease to
exist um
uh but
it's just that wars tend to be written
about a lot and whereas like uh
something being like well a normal year
where nothing
major happened was just get written
about much but that's
you know most people just like farming
and
kind of like living their life you know
um being a villager
somewhere
um
and every now and again there's a war
and i think so um
and um you know what i say like
that
there aren't very many books that i
where i just had to stop reading because
it was just too
too dark
but uh
the book about stalin the court of the
reds are
i could have stopped reading it was just
too too
dark
rough
yeah
um the 30s
uh there's a lot of lessons there to me
in particular that
it feels like
humans like all of us have that as the
old soldier it's in line
um that the line between good and evil
runs to the heart every man that all of
us are capable of evil all of us are
capable of good it's almost like this
kind of responsibility that
um all of us have to
to
to tend towards the good and so like to
me looking at history is almost like an
example of
look you have some charismatic leader
that
convinces you of things it's too easy
based on that story to do evil onto each
other onto your family and to
others and so it's like our
responsibility to do good
it's not like
now is somehow different from history
that can happen again all of it can
happen again
and yes most of the time you're right i
mean the optimistic view here is mostly
people are just living life and as
you've often memed about
the quality of life was way worse back
in the day and keeps improving over time
through innovation to technology but
still it's somehow notable that these
blimps of
atrocities happen sure
yeah i i mean life was really tough
for most of history uh i mean
for most of human history
um
a good year would be one where not that
many people in your village
died of the plague starvation freezing
to death or being killed by a
neighbouring village
it's like well it wasn't that bad you
know it was only like you know we lost
five percent this year that was uh
yeah it was a good year you know that
would be par for the course like just
just not starving to death would have
been like the primary goal of most
people in through throughout history
just making sure we'll have enough food
to last through the winter and not get
in our freezer or whatever
so
um
now food is is plentiful if i have an
obesity problem um
you know so
well yeah the lesson there is to be
grateful for the way things are now for
for some of us
you